This lesson begins by reviewing the two
dimensional linear programming problems
that high school students often
solve in their algebra two classes.
Then it extends the equations to n
dimensions and captures the essential
intuition that optimal solutions are at
the corners of the feasible region.
And we state this rigorously,
with the fundamental theorem
of linear programming.
And then finally, the lesson will
cover the simplex algorithm,
a very practical way for
solving these optimizations.
There are many good references
on linear programming.
This treatment will follow most closely,
David Luenberger's Linear and
Nonlinear Programming.
Before we begin, however, I should
mention that parts of this lecture
will use notation and
some ideas from linear algebra.
For notation,
we will use capital letters for
matrices, thus A might
be this matrix here.
For column vectors, we'll use lower case
letters, so x might be this vector here.
Also, we'll often use
the lowercase version
of a matrix to indicate a column.
Thus, a two here refers to
the second column of the matrix A.
We indicate the transpose of the matrix
by giving it a T in the superscript, and
this just reverses the meaning
of the rows and columns.
This notation, then allows us to use
C transpose X for the dot product.
This is a row vector, times
a column vector, which ends up just
as a single entry matrix, which, by
convention, we'll interpret as a scalar.
As far as concepts go, the ideas of how
to represent a system of equations as
matrices of linear
independence of vectors,
matrix rank and
matrix inverse should all be familiar.
If these ideas aren't familiar
then it would be a good idea
to refresh your understanding before
watching the rest of this lesson.
As always, it is recommended that you
watch with pencil and paper handy, so
that you can pause the video and
work out details on your own, as needed.